[Music]
if you missed your target by three
inches one way or the other you were
sometimes navigating like an arrow as we
saw crevasse between two stone walls on
either side of you if you miss you're
dead
yeah this time you were talking about
hitting a very very very tiny target yes
but not necessarily life-threatening is
that right I not so with life
threatening yeah what the hell was that
noise yeah well I mean if the my target
was still stuck between two steel poles
that were 30 feet apart and there was
still only 15 feet off the ground and if
I'd hit any of those things I still
would have died okay what right it was
still I had a larger margin for error on
this one that I've ever had into the
other one so you want to be a human
arrow and Great Wall of China yes and
this was seen on Chinese television
yes 11 different networks in China and
11 yes how many people total do you
think saw this um the estimates are in
the hundreds and hundreds of millions
Wow okay so 100 million people tuned in
and yeah and the goal was for you to do
exactly what thread this needle pretty
much basically we had a paper target
that was seven feet by three feet with a
bull's-eye in the center so the goal was
to put a GoPro this size through a
bull's eye this size traveling how fast
about 120 miles per hour and you were
launched how again from a I got out of a
helicopter about one mile away she hit a
target that small yes how was that er
using GPS how are you even I well
actually we did use GPS to mark we're
picturing a voice saying that you take a
right you know no I've arrived at your
destination though the one nice thing
about doing on the Great Wall of China
is actually able to use the Great Wall
as a marker point so I actually got out
of a helicopter over one of the top
towers and I actually rode the Great
Wall of China all the way to target and
then there was like a mountain slope and
then the Great Wall of China went right
under the slope and then I basically hit
the target on top of that slope okay
we're going to look at the stunt right
now and then I think we have two pieces
table look at the first one and talk
about it first then we have a way to
look at it from a different angle which
is much slower yes because this is going
to happen really
yes it was a very fast done alright so
talk us through what's happening here in
the helicopter obviously yes what's
really cool about this this is all live
these are all live cameras filming from
inside the chopper so if something had
gone wrong it all would have played out
alive hundreds of millions of yen this
was one of the first times we actually
had the technology to do live while
we're flying my cameraman is telling me
live and all my cameras on my face all
live too so and there you hit your
target
yes you cred about going how fast you
think alright it's hard to tell from
that angle so we have now a what would
you call this say this is a different
angle that's a still great that's a
still friend grab that's my GoPro going
through the exact dead center of the
bullseye it looks like you hit it
exactly yes my GoPro went directly
through the dead center of the bullseye
so at the last second are used to you're
still making adjustments up until the
last microsecond to get your go actually
you can see I actually start leaning my
head so what I do is I have my GoPro on
a post and I'm actually looking at the
the GoPro and I'm using it as a target
so as I'm coming in at my target I'm
looking at it I'm trying to literally
lean my head into that little spot
you